buenos dias raúl bueno efectivamente el
día de ayer escuchábamos a diversos
oradores representantes de japón canadá
e italia la unión europea y refiriendo a
tu pregunta del mandatario de palestina
abbas no quien se dirigió este viernes
en la asamblea general de las naciones
unidas para insistir precisamente en
esto afirmar esa concepción de identidad
nacional palestina y además hizo
hincapié en que algo me llamó mucho la
atención por supuesto que los acuerdos
de los emiratos árabes unidos e israel'
violarían la iniciativa de paz árabe
esto por supuesto desde la postura del
representante palestino no habrá que
esperar y ver cómo continúa la situación
antonella en la jornada ayer también se
pronunció el presidente del consejo
europeo charles michel quien dejó claro
que en la nueva rivalidad entre eeuu y
china la unión europea sigue conformando
con washington una alianza vital aunque
precisó que eso no evita que en
ocasiones tenga enfoques e intereses
divergentes le pregunto entonces cuál es
la verdadera posición del bloque europeo
frente a ese conflicto
estas dos potencias absolutamente el
presidente del consejo europeo charles
michel dejó bien en claro el día de ayer
en la asamblea general de las naciones
unidas que en esta nueva rivalidad entre
los eeuu y china la unión europea y va a
continuar conformando como bien lo
mencionaste raúl con washington lo que
michelle llamó una alianza vital
precisamente remarcando esa profunda
relación con los eeuu con quien además
según mencionó se comparten ideas lazos
valores y un afecto mutuo de alguna
forma que se ha desarrollado por
supuesto a lo largo de la historia y
además míchel subrayó
algo que también es bastante llamativo
que de europa comparte o no quizás esto
tenemos que verlo desde desde el punto
de perspectiva si es china este si es
eeuu pero europa no comparte los valores
en los que se levanta tal vez el sistema
político económico chino xi jinping
un sistema abiertamente comunista
acusado también por violaciones a los
derechos humanos
respecto al sistema político económico
del que hablo
michelle ayer en la onu china es uno de
los de los países que está al final de
aquel índice de libertad económica
elaborado por la fundación heritage en
washington dc no ubicando a china
prácticamente en el puesto 103 y siendo
un país con libertades económicas
reprimidas así que si efectivamente yo
veo una una clara distinción cultural
económica social que conecta mucho más a
la unión europea con los eeuu por
supuesto muy rápidamente en donde la que
podemos esperar para hoy
bueno yo creo que hoy va a ser un día
también de jornada bien interesante es
vamos a tener también varios países
latinoamericanos creo que también
respecto de américa latina' la gran
cuestión es saber qué vamos a hacer nos
ofrece esta crisis del coi 19 que nos
afecta tan duro y tan gravemente yo creo
que acá lo que necesitamos precisamente
a nivel regional es acabar con estos
autoritarismos acabar con los populismos
y además con las restricciones
exorbitantes que vemos por doquier no a
lo largo de la región hoy más que nunca
yo creo necesitamos apelar a la
responsabilidad individual hoy más que
nunca necesitamos menos estado más
libertad más comercio más apertura más
facilidad para abrir empresas e incluso
menos impuestos y creo que bueno todas
estas temáticas de coyuntura regional
van a ser un tema que nada haciendo
hincapié en el cob y 19 y la crisis y
cómo impacta antonella gracias por estar
con nosotros